your speed dating continues with me
it is like speed dating 100 like it um i
really want to start with a sincere
thank you i really enjoy both of your
work and uh you guys are great in this
and i just want to say thank you for
what you do
thank you thank you
lovely to hear
uh i i've spoken to a lot of actors and
they talk about how if they're nervous
to take on a role they they immediately
gravitate towards it it's like it
excites them and i'm curious with this
movie where either of you nervous to
take on this role and did that actually
drive you to want to do it
i mean i wasn't nervous initially i was
just so excited because it was
brilliantly written and these things
don't come along often and when aaron
sorkin says here i want you to play this
role and you read it and you go what
yes oh my god i'm so excited
i was nervous once i started
trying to do the voice and
realized how much work was ahead
but initially i was like ow yeah
well yes i mean
it is uh it is
i changed the role i love i love i love
the role and uh
way before it was
basically written
i knew about the project before he was
even breeder and i i i follow it and i
was very much into trying to get it
and finally
fate came back to me and gave it to me
and
and i was
and once i
landed on yes i i was very nervous
because
now is when the theory stops and you
have to make it real
and there's a lot of
responsibility with it
absolutely um
like i said at the top of this i am a
really big fan of both of your work and
i am i love talking to actors about the
way they prepare for roles and i'm
curious for both of you if you
hypothetically have like a huge scene on
a monday it's very dramatic it's very
emotional you know it's going to be
something that is going to take
something out of you can you sort of
talk about the way you like to prepare
leading up to that day are you like long
time you know like a week or two or a
month out thinking about it or is it
more closer to when you're actually
going to film it
i think there's always one scene or two
scenes in a movie where you go
when are we playing that scene
next tuesday oh god
uh
every scene in this film though
everything in this film though
that wasn't an easy day
right
yeah i mean it was like
wow
which is great because the scenes are so
rich and deep and interesting
but
enormous amount of um how do you prepare
for that i i guess how do you prepare
i don't know you just
that's what we do for a living i mean
would you just go there and try to be
a vessel muscle vessel
yeah and i think it's the collision of
relaxation with terror where you're
going and preparation and then
relaxing and letting it flow so it's
just it's very hard to talk about it
because you just it's like what
what we do what we've i mean i've been
i've been doing this since i was 14. but
this was literally the hardest job i've
ever had
and that's saying something
it was so so hard
but at the same time incredibly
exhilarating and a gift
yeah i i thought you guys did such a
great job and uh obviously aaron is a
genius um i got to go
yeah
absolutely yeah
thank you for your time and good luck
with your dating
thank you thank you
you